let's talk about debt a little bit okay
we talked about you know spending money
on cars let's talk about that so
basically you know this is some smart
advice for the people at home so i saw
this article you know what
let's weigh in on this right so top
money experts will go boom boom boom
boom boom they're basically giving their
top advice about
getting out of debt and understanding
debt so we're just going to go down the
list here there's five experts that
we're going to talk about here you tell
me which one you think is the best
advice of these five experts you tell me
which is the best advice okay we'll
start off
with the king of no debt
dave ramsey dave so dave ramsey says
decide you're done with debt this is
what dave ramsey has to say he says
there could be no such thing as
debt-free life without discipline i
agree with that quote unquote first
things first i'm popping no first things
first
decide you're done with debt yeah okay
right now dave dave energy hates debt
okay that means there's no more swiping
that credit card no more taking out
personal loans none of that stuff if you
can't pay for any cash you ain't buying
it yeah that's dave ramsey for you so
basically how would i look at this treat
debt like a crazy ex-girlfriend or
ex-boyfriend okay
at some point you got to cut that out of
your life forever and never look back i
haven't had debt in my life since i paid
off my student loans
and it's amazing feeling to not have to
owe anybody anything yeah freaking great
yeah it's freaking great
i told sally may listen you dirty ass
i'm done with you i'm breaking up with
you for good sally
keep it moving that's a great feeling
whether you're paying off your your
student loans your car loan your credit
card loan a freaking mortgage somehow to
be debt-free is an amazing feeling an
empowering feeling i encourage
i highly encourage it oh i'm choking up
over here all right you know who else uh
does not love debt sues ormond susie
ormond do you know who susie is no susie
excuse me no i don't
susie orman is basically like the female
dave ramsey all right okay
she's got a with better hair oh
dave ramsey there's there's she is right
there there she is
pull her up there's susie armor have you
ever seen her no but she's
probably
yeah she definitely doesn't have uh the
nice quality i would say suzy orman
basically says
sorry yeah she does
susie orman actually looks like a karen
i i didn't want to say it i didn't want
to say susie karen norman
yeah yes there she basically says that
not all dead is created equal
says
um karen orman
oh come on and it shouldn't be
prioritized that way either which i
actually agree with so basically there's
different levels of this she said i
would not be tackling all in the same
way you know so basically you got
student loans you got mortgages you got
uh car loans you got credit card loans
you got consumer debt right
you've got um
cash advances right so what i call the
seas of debt college yeah credit cards
cars consumer loans credit um credit
cards i said um
cash advances there's different levels
to this stuff understand there's three
things if you're gonna figure out debt
the name of the debt
the amount of the debt and the interest
rate that you're paying and then you can
utilize you know if you want to go the
dave ramsey approach you go to the debt
snowball pay it off or you go to the
debt avalanche way different ways but
there's levels to this thing that's
susie orman aka
according to david karen third piece of
advice is from a lady named farnoosh
torrabi
aka you're so money baby you're so money
you don't even know it she's actually a
pretty famous person in the personal
finance world she says
uh um basically you ever heard set it
and forget it set it and forget it get
it you've heard that before i actually
believe that investing listen said it
that's exactly and forget it it doesn't
work necessarily that way when it comes
to debt she basically says this like she
gets the set it approach especially if
when it comes to um
paying off debts and eliminating it but
one thing you can't do is forget it
okay she says yeah she said i like the
senate part but not the forget it part
she goes that entails basically tuning
out and hoping for the best shame with
that neither am i that's farnoosh
torrabi number four this is from a lady
who's actually a big name in the in the
um the personal finance world the
budgenista her real name is tiffany
alasha she says spend wisely my friends
and only on essentials so if you're in
debt you got to understand the
difference between essential and
non-essential we learned the word
essential for sure during covey if
you're an essential worker and not a
central worker you or no our friend
gerard's got a non-essential tattoo on
his neck that's how non-essentially he
was during children
uh the government came and tattooed yeah
they said this is an essential buddy
your jokes your opinions they are
essential so he says the only way to
real well real way to eliminate debt is
to stop spending your way into it
understanding the difference between
essential and non-essential couldn't
agree more you got needs wants savings
get debt you've heard of the 50 30 20
rule 50 goes to your needs 30 to your
wants 20 so you're saving and paying off
debt
understand that the wants they can be
moving over to the uh saving or paying
off debt category boom now you're living
debt-free and the last but not least
is that money should not be a secret
when you're talking to your family money
is very taboo right yeah we don't talk
about it in our family how much you're
making it's how much
what you know what you what's your
investment profile you know keeping
money secret so this guy's a new york
times best seller his name is neil
godfrey he says quote unquote anything
anything that involves money and the
exchange of value
can be used as a learning tool for your
kids
okay or for young people in your family
there's no way to expect kids to grow up
with a healthy attitude toward money
unless they know how it works of course
so don't keep it a secret
i meet with my eight-year-old nephew
i say
save that money oh believe me save that
money but i say
um adorable
the best rory i say if you take out the
garbage yeah i'm gonna give you five
dollars
okay yeah and then sometimes i'll say if
you take out the garbage i'll give you a
quarter and he's like
nah i'm good
yeah i'm good buddy yeah i'm good buddy
so he understands because when you're a
kid oh a quarter a dollar like
understand the value the fair exchange
of okay cool
hey if you do this i'm gonna give you 20
oh damn what's up what do we get what do
we got to do yeah hey if you do this i'm
gonna give you a shiny nickel
yeah i'm good
back in my day
so this is all great advice so shout out
to dave ramsey susie orman farnoosh the
budgetista
and uh the new york times seller neil
godfrey all good advice all good advice
um because when you get out of debt you
can save that money you can start
investing there's levels of stuff out
there
okay
let's move on because nobody loves
talking about debt it's one of those
things that when you get it out of your
life you feel great but when it's in
your life you're brah
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken